за його Сергій шойгу пробудемо дитинства
копію рейхстагу dry військових ігор
дзвони слухати вони були резонанс або
троянда мене відсоток разу за видами allow
символ акива дає сир диких apple
ялиновий ти ж навик шпігель
інший масово поза матчем не азат образ
не травневий політолог штефан майстер
говорити про подальше викрадення ні мати
до російських видно син за словами
експерта таким чином біт відбувається store
стереотипи та все спірс тві та у молодого
покоління створити дали негативний
образ не міченим, а голова московського
бюро німецького фонду імені Фрідріха
наумана обожнюю рахунку приватний тренд
Росії за посилання конфронтації то
мілітаризації when the cage адже знач
ще кремль
інструменту лізу та історії за для
голосну метт і я і забирати покриваються
холодним потом кіл і у є без
чумою but німу не російські патріоти
вимагатимуть назад штурмом німецька
рекс тах одна з найбільших проблем у
Росії сьогодні нами і політ c1000
соромиться праворуч
сама ідентифікація за допомогу
реконструкції військового голови за
допомогою патріотизму а депутат
європарламенту ельмар брок за так все
телком закономірним харчуванням думаєте на
уазик дивували їхню ставку трохи iv нацизму
про приватний рейс тах я кому з 1999
руку засідай німецький парламент
бундестаг якщо справа і допиту дж
основу здивую великі засід німецька
парламент просто символ слухати який
демократії то цеху його шляхом у випад qc
однозначно агресивний акт проти
нинішнього не матч і не олексія дитини
прокопію 2 чи будемо імітації історично та
будили рейхстагу
і як штурмувала червона армія в чому і
волосся нацистського не шинкою тодес
історичній точці zara
частіше можна прийняти ми згорнулася до
прес-служби міністерства оборони Росії
проте там видно волосся команд увата
заяву шейху